we all want to make sure that our food
is safe but doing that can be really
hard looking for contaminants in raw
materials is tough the statistics are
stacked against us today we can only
test for pathogens individually one
sample at a time and that means hundreds
is not thousands of tests most of which
that were simple negatively we needed to
think about this differently that's why
Mars and IBM join forces to sequence the
genomes of all the organisms in the food
supply chain that's millions of
organisms a big data is what iBM is good
at the DNA and RNA sequences show you
all the harmless bacteria that are found
in normal safe food if we do the test
and the microorganisms are suddenly
different something's up the organisms
have changed because the environment has
changed it could be contaminated and not
only that this tells us things that we
never could have seen before like where
the food was grown how it was
transported and maybe even what happened
on route our approach to food safety
just got a lot smarter